Gut.
Ja, hallo, guten Abend.
Ün was ist mein Name?
Ich bin Asistan Ersten, hier tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich, Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir.
So erst würde ich ein paar Fragen so in der Person stellen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Irma Müller.
Können Sie bitte mit Ihrem Vor- und Nachnamen buchtebieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist Irma.
Und der Familienname ist Müller.
Im Umlaut, doppel L, Ir.
Siehst Sie Frau?
Ja, eine Frau.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 37 Jahre.
Was sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 13.07.1986.
Okay, 18.08.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Oh, ich wiege so 69 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Sie fragen schwierige Sachen, 1 Meter, 68.
18.08.
Ja, 18.08.
Okay, was für Sie uns, was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ja, ich habe solche heftigen Bauchschmerzen.
Und zwar, ich habe es eigentlich nach dem Mittagessen angefangen.
Da habe ich erst gedacht, dass es irgendwie mit dem Essen zusammenhängt.
Da war das so auf Magenhöhe.
Und dann ist es aber nachher so runtergewandert auf die rechte Seite.
Das sind ganz stechende und krampfige Schmerzen.
Die werden irgendwie immer schlimmer.
Ich hatte jetzt gehofft, es würde sich vielleicht verbessern,
wenn ich mich im Moment hinlege.
Aber im Liegen ging es überhaupt nicht.
Und, ja, was dann so erträglich war,
wenn ich mich so auf dem Stuhl so zusammengehockt habe, ja,
und so die Beine ganz eng angezogen,
dann dachte ich so, jetzt kann ich es ein bisschen aushalten.
Aber ich habe gedacht, bis morgen früh kann ich damit nicht warten.
Da muss ich heute Abend noch irgendwie zum Arzt gehen.
Ja, okay. Das ist eine weiße Einschaltung ins Krakno zu kommen.
Umgefallen, seit wie viele Stunden haben Sie diese Beschwerde?
Naja, jetzt haben wir es acht.
Ich würde sagen, seit angefangen hat es so vor sechs, sieben Stunden.
Sechs, sieben Stunden.
Okay, sind Sie sich Beschwerden plötsch oder wachsam angefangen?
Ich würde sagen, die sind plötzlich aufgetreten, ja,
und dann immer schlimmer geworden.
Okay.
Wo war die Schmerz in Amfarkt, genau?
Am Anfang so, ja, da dachte ich halt, es ist das mit dem Magen,
da war das so um den Bauchnabern, so unterhalb der Rippen.
Ja.
Aber in der Mitte.
Und jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, dass es so nach rechts und umgewandert ist.
Alles klar.
Okay, die Schmerzen, genau, wie schreiben Sie,
die haben wir schon gesagt, heftige, kraftartige Schmerzen.
Sind Sie eher dummstrücken, stehend?
Nee, eher stehend.
Stehend.
Okay.
Schmerzen, die schmerzen eh gut wohin aus, zum Beispiel in der Mitte.
Ich würde sagen, Straustralentunni, die sind so auf dem Bauch,
jetzt auf die rechte Seite beschränkt.
Alles klar.
Wie starten Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz,
Skalafone 0 bis 10, Vorball 0, kein 10, sehr stark ist.
Ja, das ist schwer, allen zu schätzen.
Also jetzt sind die, würde ich sagen, so zwischen 6 und 7.
6 und 7, okay.
Aber am Anfang war es nicht so schlimm, ne?
Okay, alles klar.
Sie haben stark geschmeißen,
könnte Sie bitte diese Schmerzen noch ein bisschen aushalten.
Am Ende gespielt, kann ich Ihnen sofort ein Schmerz mitgeben.
Ja, ja, wenn das irgendwie hilfreich ist,
dass Sie da erstmal alle Fragen stellen, klar, warte, dann.
Ich habe das ja schon ein paar Stunden.
Okay.
Sie haben schon erweitert, dass die Schmerzen nach dem Mittagessen
angefangen haben.
Ja, angefangen, ja.
Was haben Sie denn angegessen am Mittagessen?
Ja, ich habe Gemüse und Kartoffeln gegessen
und so gebratene Hackfleischbällchen
und zum Nachtisch Pudding und Obst, also irgendwie nichts Auffälliges.
Okay, okay, ich stand.
Okay.
Für Sie hatten Sie ähnliche Wäsche, oder ist das erst das?
Nein, ich kenne das überhaupt nicht solche Bauchschmerzen.
Also klar, kenne ich Bauchschmerzen, wenn ich meine Periode habe
oder als ich die Kinder bekommen habe.
Aber nee, solche Bauchschmerzen kenne ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ob nicht hilfreich.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Haben Sie bestimmte Auslöserbemerk für diese Schmerzen, oder?
Ja, angefangen hat es nach dem Essen, aber ja,
und ich musste mich auch einmal übergeben,
und mir ist es schlecht, aber ich habe jetzt irgendwie nicht so den Eindruck,
dass das vom Magen herkommt, weil es jetzt mehr so im Unterbau auch nicht tut.
Alles klar, ich vererste.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch Übelkeit?
Ja, schlecht ist mir schon auch, ja.
Ja, okay.
Wie sieht Ihre Albrecherne aus?
Ist das ewig?
Ja, das war das Mittagessen halt, was ich gegessen hatte.
Okay.
Sie haben einmal eine Brücke?
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber oder fühlen Sie sich fieblich?
Gemessen habe ich nicht, aber tatsächlich haben Sie recht,
ich fühle mich so ein bisschen heiß,
und jetzt ist es natürlich auch heute ein warmer Tag,
aber ich fühle mich schon ein bisschen fieblich, würde ich schon sagen,
ja, aber wie gesagt, gemessen habe ich das nicht.
Alles klar.
Leiden Sie unter Schüterfrost, Schweißausbrüche oder Lauchschweiß?
Nein, nein, normalerweise überhaupt nicht,
und jetzt habe ich auch kein Schüttelfrost, nein.
Okay, alles klar.
Also, ja.
Haben Sie Veränderungen beim Wasserlassen bemerkt?
In der letzten Zeit haben Sie...
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Nicht okay.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Sturggarten?
Haben Sie Durchfall oder Verstufung oder ganz normal?
Ich würde sagen ganz normal.
Ganz normal? Okay.
Wann war die letzte Sturg?
Um.
Ich würde sagen, ich habe heute Morgen war das, ja.
Ja, ich fahre jetzt in Ordnung,
haben Sie ja auffälliges Bemerkt?
Verstufung?
Nein, da ist mir nichts aufgefallen, das war so wie immer.
Alles klar. Gehen Sie auch, oder Probleme?
Sie meinen, dass ich Blähungen habe, oder was?
Gehen Sie ab?
Ja, zwischendurch habe ich manchmal Blähungen,
aber jetzt heute nicht extrem.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, schwindelig ist mir nicht schlecht,
ist mir nur ein Bauch, wie habe ich.
Okay.
Haben Sie Sauerausstoßen, Sotbremnen?
Nein, das kenne ich gar nicht.
Ist Ihnen Herzstöpeln oder Brustschweißen aufgefallen?
Nein, da oben tut nichts weh mit, nur der Bauch.
Alles klar.
Wie ist Ihr Repetit?
Ja.
Das ist normal, ist sehr gut, aber heute ist mir überhaupt nicht nach Essen zu moten.
Okay. Haben Sie Interesse seit Ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Ich weh mich jetzt nicht jeden Tag, aber ich meine, das ist stabil.
Ja, alles klar.
Frau Amina, ich hätte eine Frage,
Sie leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen,
wie Bluthoff, Röck, Zuckerkrankheit, Asthma, Geist, oder?
Ja, also, was ich habe, ich habe so ein bisschen chronische Bronchitis,
also gerade im ganzen Herbst und Winter über,
habe ich immer viel im Sommer geht,
aber wenn die kalte Jahreszeit kommt, habe ich oft so Husten.
Und, was ich eben auch habe,
bei mir ist eine schildrösen Unterfusion bekannt,
deswegen muss ich immer Turoxin nehmen.
Turoxin, ja.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie diese Krankheiten?
Erstmal chronische Bronchitis, seit wann?
Ach, das habe ich eigentlich schon als Schülerin gehabt,
oder als junge Frau, also das habe ich bestimmt schon 15 Jahre.
Ja?
Und die Schildröse, das hat man erst so vor 7, 8 Jahren festgestellt.
Okay, 7, 8 Jahre.
Okay, wissen Sie, die Dosierung von Eltroxin?
Das kann ich Ihnen jetzt gerade nicht sagen, was da drauf steht.
Das wird ja immer angepasst und ich weiß jetzt nicht, ich habe den Zettel zu Hause.
Alles klar.
Sie nehmen einen Meinmorgens, oder?
Ja.
Okay, nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein,
Oisal Eltroxin?
Nee, sonst denkst du, nein, nein.
Alles klar.
Frau Amida wurde sich schon einmal operiert.
Das ist aber schon sehr, sehr lange her.
Als Kind habe ich mal die Mandeln rausgekommen, als ich 10 Jahre alt war.
Ja, das weiß, oder?
Sonst?
Ja, also Kinder sind spontan gekommen.
Ja, ja, nicht so.
Also keine OP sonst.
Alles klar.
Ist Ihnen Allergien beckert?
So weit ich weiß, habe ich keine Allergie.
Also ich glaube, ich kann wirklich alles vertragen.
Ich bin nicht ein ganz gesunder Mensch.
Okay, alles klar.
Wann war Ihre nächste Brutung, Monas Brutung?
Ja, das ist jetzt zweieinhalb Wochen her.
So, hallo, ist das möglich, dass Sie schwanger sind?
Würde ich ausgehen.
Ja, okay.
Hatte Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Reise oder waren Sie im Ausland?
Nein, wir waren im Sommerurlaub, aber nicht im Ausland.
Alles klar.
Trauen Sie, Frau Mugler?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Ja, das ist super, prima.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, hin und wieder trinke ich mal ein Glas Wein, aber wirklich nicht so ganz oft.
Alles klar.
Jetzt würde ich gerne ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie.
Leben beide Eltern, ne?
Die leben beide noch zum Glück, ja, ja.
Ja, leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen, erst mal Vater.
Weil Vater, der hatte mal so Herzprobleme.
Da hat man vermutet, dass er vielleicht einen kleinen Herzinfarkt hatte,
den hat er aber gut überstanden.
Und jetzt kriegt er Medikamente.
Und jetzt geht es um die Erkrankungen.
Und jetzt geht es ihm eigentlich sogar gut.
Und meine Mutter ist gesund.
Ja, meine Mutter geht so.
Okay.
Hatte Ihr Vater einen Herzkriminalunterzug, oder?
Ich meine, das haben die damals gemacht,
kann auch sein, dass sie da irgendwie ein Stent reingesetzt haben.
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr so ganz genau.
Aber da war er mal eine Weile in der Klinik.
Alles klar.
Hab es dir geschwistert?
Eine Schwester habe ich ja.
Ist dir gesund?
Leider nicht.
Die hat irgendwie im relativ frühem Alter die Brustkrebs bekommen.
Ja, ich meine beide.
Aber sie ist behandelt und wir hoffen, dass sie alles überstanden hat.
Ja, sehr gut, ja.
Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich arbeite bei einer Versicherung.
Ja, im Büro meinst du?
Ja, das ist Büroarbeit, genau.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstadt?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Verheiratet.
Okay. Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder, ein Sohn, eine Tochter.
Okay. Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, zum Glück sind die gerne gesund.
Okay.
Frau Amina, ich habe jetzt meine alle Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ich wüsste es nicht, habe Ihnen so viel erzählt.
Insofern denke ich, dass da nichts mehr ist, was ich Ihnen noch erzähle.
Ich möchte natürlich jetzt gerne wissen, was das sein kann
und ob ich im Krankenhaus bleiben muss
und wie wird es direkt bekommen, diese Schmerzen, ja?
Ja.
Das würde mich schon interessieren.
Aber sonst, dass ich jetzt noch etwas Zusätzliches erzählen kann,
fällt mir nichts ein.
Okay.
Ja, jetzt ist es so früh etwas genau zu sagen.
Aber ich denke, Sie haben Probleme.
Ich denke, Sie haben Probleme.
Sie haben eine Bilitärm-Einzündung.
Ich habe jetzt nur ein paar Unterzugs,
wie Körperlöschen, Luftunterzugs und Optum-Nutrosonografien.
Nach der Unterzugsergebnis kann ich Ihnen general sagen,
was für Ihre ist.
Ja, okay.
Ich möchte Ihnen für weitere Untersuchungen und Behandlungen bei uns bleiben.
Muss ich denn stationär bleiben?
Ja, ja, wahrscheinlich ja.
Okay.
Da muss ich zu Hause Bescheid sagen, dass die mir meine Sachen bringen.
Ja, es wäre gut, ja.
Aber machen wir keine Sorgen.
Wir besitzen im Krankenhaus die nötige Sachen.
Ah, das ist auch gut, dass ich erst mal über die Runden komme.
Ich weiß, ich meine, man kann erst mal um die Kinder kommen.
Ja, wir schauen, wie das geht.
Genau, genau.
Gut, alles klar.
Wie gewaltig Sie? Ich rufe Sie gleich.
Super, ja.
Danke.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen?
Entschuldigung, ich konnte heute nicht so viel zu hören.
Weil das Internet nicht funktioniert?
Nein, mit meinem Computer.
Ah, okay, ja.
Manchmal ist das so.
Dann kommen von Ihnen schon mal keine Fragen.
Vielleicht im Status, wir haben noch nicht.
Ja, im Status hat sie nicht gefragt, genau.
Also ich bin natürlich gegen alles klassische geimpft
und Corona bin ich auch geimpft.
Ansonsten würde ich sagen, ja.
Ich habe keine Fragen, ich denke, ja.
Ich glaube, sie hat sehr vollständig gefragt.
Da waren sehr komplett, würde ich sagen, hat sie alles abgefragt.
Ich wüsste nicht, was ich auf meinem Zettel habe, was ich nicht gesagt habe.
Ja, okay.
Können wir als Tatsuki-Jigre anfangen?
Kommt mir aus immer?
Ja, okay.
Hallo, guten Abend Frau Oberarstein.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin gesehen.
Hättest du sie seit, für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ja, die Patientin heißt Irma Müller.
Frau Müller ist 37 Jahre alt, geboren,
3 Jahre alt, 1900,
6 Jahre alt, 1 Meter alt, 6 Jahre alt,
9 Jahre alt, 6 Jahre alt,
7 Jahre alt, heute,
5 Jahre alt,
6 Jahre alt,
die Patientin heißt Plustrosaia,
sie ist für die Patientin pylolisiert.
Sie ist in der Urflugung ge jacketiert,
in der Urflugung,
Sie sind in den Unterbauch gewandert, ja?
Wie gewandert? Ja.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt 6 bis 7 auf einer der Schmerzschmerzkarate.
Genannt, ja.
Ja, genannt.
Die Frage nach Ausstrahlung für ihre ähnliche Medikamente und Ausröser für den Verneid.
Er hat die ähnliche Beschwerdengesamen.
Ja, ich habe die ähnliche Beschwerdengesamen gebeten.
Sie sind sehr früh, sehr viel bricht, aber es sind auch sehr wenige.
Die Beschwerden sind mit einer typischen Maschine.
Die Frage, die vegetative Anamnese ergab, ist in Appätenz.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufwendig, bis auf in Appätenz wegen dieser Beschwerden.
Die Frage, die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufwendig, bis auf in Appätenz wegen dieser Beschwerden.
Anvorerkrankungen.
Anvorerkrankungen leiden sie seit 14 Jahren.
Seit acht Jahren, hypotroösa, als Medikament nimmt sie elterupsin unklarer dosis einmal morgens.
Sie wurde mit St. Eleventi, Tonsidöktömi, allergien bestündet nicht.
Die letzte Monatpolitik war vor zwei Wochen.
Die nonksonische Anamnese ist unaufwendig, bis auf Alkoholkonsum eingelasset.
Bei der Anamnese fanden sie Coronare-Herzkrankheit, bei dem Vater.
Die Mutter ist gesund. Sie arbeitet bei Versicherung.
Die Anamnese ist auf einer akuten Appendisität.
Die Anamnese ist unaufwendig, bis auf Gravidität.
Die Schadam-Erkrankungen in Betra.
Ich möchte die Patientin körperisch untersuchen.
Ich achte, ob Abwehrspannung, Schmeißung oder Druckschmeißung gibt.
Ich messe die Vitalparameter auf, weil die Patientin 50 war.
Ich erneuere die Vitalparameter, ich erneuere die Blutabendizid.
Was erwarten Sie, wenn es eine Appendizid ist?
Ich arbeite sehr arpenweite und mit der Koalitionskrise.
Das müsste man gleich sehen.
Was machen Sie weiter für Untersuchungen?
Ich möchte eine Abzuhlmung durchführen.
Bei der Sonografie erwarte ich Darwart, Verdüken oder Freiflüstigkeit neben der Appendizid.
Ich mache sofort ein schüro-griechisches Konzi.
Ich bin schon ein Schritt weiter.
Wenn Sie eine Blinder am Entzündung haben, würde man den ausnehmen.
Heute würde man minimalinvasiv abhändektorieren.
Ich bin sehr stolz auf die Patientin.
Ich bin gespannt, wie Sie mich berichten über Ihre Untersuchungsergebnisse.
Im schlimmsten Fall sehen wir uns dann wieder im OK.
Das war ziemlich gut.
Das war eine sehr schöne Anamnese.
Ich gebe zu, dass die Appendizid nicht exotisch ist.
Aber es ist häufig nicht der Appendix.
In Deutschland wurden noch sehr viele Blinder operativ entfernt.
Heute ist man deutlich zurückhaltender.
Die Symptome sind sehr klassisch beschrieben.
Da liegen Sie auf der richtigen Seite.
Ich habe nur ein paar Sachen gefunden.
Nicht meine Fragen, sondern meine Fragen.
Ich habe mich schnell notiert, aber nicht richtig.
Nach der Untersuchung.
Was viel besser geworden ist, ist mit dem E dazwischen.
Das machen Sie nicht mehr ganz so oft.
Es gab viele fließende Sätze.
Ich habe mich nicht in den Fragen bereitet.
Es ist eine gute Gelegenheit, sich noch einmal zu sammeln.
Ich finde es sehr gut.
Ich habe mich sehr großartig diskutiert.